Right. Being gay and being here
and bill includes both part of the
reason for me coming here would probably
be most sexuality in that at
the time living in queensland
and if you know in a structure which
still hadn't accepted homosexuality.
It was restrictive and i guess
i felt that i couldn't see why
that should be me why i had to go through
all that bullshit then coming here.
And still i suppose in there is
i think you know sort of that.
You do have to be careful that sense
of you know survival thing where you.
You know if you care if you test the
water out before you jump in it.
But then thinking of like you know these
are all people you know finding out
that you know they're diverse you know
that actually we're all so different
you know and individuality.
And you look at other people you see you
know you think yourselves you think you
know this is actresses reapers
are that furthers really.
So we'll examine trick as a here right
back to the way they are to love.
You know why can't i just bring be
myself in and bring that i speak to me.
And so then sort of you know i suppose
thinking well you know you can you can go
overboard in these things you can sort of
you know sort of guys say oh i'm well.
And i'm gay and i'm a fourth guy you know
and if that's their excess they're out
you know fuck off as you know know.
Without having to do that.
So just interacting with people
and then finding the way you know is he
will find out what you are all about us
either they accept it
or they don't. They do.
Well that's you know that their problem
and they're not worth knowing.
But finding actually finding.
In the 10 years i've been here i've never
had anyone put me down for my sexuality
to my face. That is. And.
I suppose overall
that people just accept me for the way
they put me down for other things
and being the treasurer of all inclusive.
Let's create you know what
you do with our money.
Are you fuckwit.
But not for my sexuality. If anything.
Quite the officers.
That some people really like to
key into that they're like that.
And they like you for your other aspects
you know they're i think people basically
like people who if you. If they
feel comfortable with you.
You know if they feel you're okay
in you not there to hurt and
or do anything you know sort of bad
against them or whatever and also
that you know i think people key into
your energy is this if you if you sort of
stable in yourself if you're.
Contented within yourself that
that shows that that come about.
I think part of that stability
is being honest with yourself
and just expressing yourself
as you are you know.
One enhances the other and that overrides
all those other negative aspects.
And yeah. Finding that people
just accept that. I do find that.
Especially when with the guys
around here the male. There are.
There is sort of probably tolerance in
some people rather than acceptance of.
What it would ever and maybe that.
They'll interact you know
sure you know you do things
but there's a limitation as to
how close you can get. Two.
But there are a lot of guys around who
are don't mind getting close at all.
Into the warrior. Which is great.
Just to give our guys because
you know i think being male
and as i think male liberation is
yet to come is well overdue for
me
and i really need even here
in the old turn a deaf.
Friend. And actually being gay here.
It's not been a problem.
The only thing lately i'm finding is probably
now because i possibly feel a need to
get back into a relationship and for
that to happen when you're in a village
that you know still
that president has very minimal
contact with the outside world.
It's it's a difficult thing to
do i think it's a sort of place
that if you want to settle down there with
a relationship in a relationship here
that you need to find your relationship and
come here rather than finding it here.
Also.
Things expressing
that to a lot of people i found a lot
of people say oh you know like i got a
brother is gay or my son
is gay and stuff like that
that maybe that's not the case.
But anyway.
I mean.
I just know you know i don't think it's
there may have i think at the time.
A number of it here or going
through a sort of change period
and maybe even though this is
a very beautiful place to.
These and i mean it's fantastic.
And if you've ever been around the world
over to parts of the world to other
countries you know soon realize that
and we live in utopia
here it is very emplaced.
But also i think the realization that.
Once you are in something for a
period time you take it for granted.
And even though you're in an
environment that's brilliant.
After a while you take it for granted and
you possibly need a change you need.
Blood positive negative things you
know you can't always know or.
Being happy is unless you
experience the offers that.
And so you need a change
you need to get away
and then sometimes you get
overpowered was. Politics.
And even on politics in everything you
can actually help pay for a very.
And
that can sort of make you unhappy say things
like i don't want to say i don't need
this anymore. I want to get out of
here. But i want to do something out.
I need to break away i need
to get different stimulation.
And then through.
I don't know whether it's circumstances
that i think i actually say we created
even if we don't realize that doing.
A radio cause in radio programming
and from.
The that's right.
I got involved after
that stage of sort of you know
sort of a bit of a change going on
and i started i got involved with doing
a course in radio programming and
that was through taif and
was more and part of
that was actually doing experience at the.
Ensign are. F.m. So a community radio.
Which was then at the college
the northern rivers college at
that particular time and during that.
Because we're talking with the
program manager at the station
and she asked me what sort of program.
I was looking at doing and
and i at the time i thought well i suppose
if i want to do a program be something
you do is something a bit radical
or gay people or something like
that gay program.
And then sometime after
that she then approached me about actually
doing the program there was a gay
program called gay ways gay and
lesbian program i should say so.
Called gay ways. And.
She asked me if if i get involved
with that program and i thought about
and i thought i ok.
And sort of circumstance at the time
sort of created that too i suppose.
Sort of coming back from
sydney and getting stuck
and losing all because we had
a flight on a particular time
and staying at the radio station to
help them case out the muti equipment
and then finding us doing on air
programming for the first time and then
when i started getting involved
with the actual gateways program.
And at that particular
time sort of finding
that it really need to be restructured to
create a better program for homosexual
people. And approaching a friend and
asking her if she could get involved
and she agreed and through
that involvement and.
She was actually the one that expressed
that she'd like to have gay dancers around
the area because there really wasn't any
way with that homosexual
people would go to to meet.
And so i created.
And then the realisation then that we needed
a group of people to set the dance up.
So then came the idea of
we need a gay group here
and even though there had
been various. Groups and.
So to come and gone and i think along
with the northern rivers gay group
and the other was some
land some langauge group
that they really didn't last
long and sort of died out.
So we then went about
trying to form a group
that was a lot of work for you know a lot
of running around a lot of structuring
but very positive stuff with getting i was
finding actually i was getting back a
lot of very positive feedback
and. They quite intrigued me.
Because also.
Some people had expressed
that wouldn't happen
that there's too much
homophobia around still
and especially in lismore in particular
newspaper and leaves more at
that particular time was very
anti-gay with their article
but not really keying into
that i couldn't really see
that i suppose because of being a bill
and with sort of tend to be
somewhat isolated from the.
You can get so locked up in
the place where you're living
that you know every day and
then you realize oh wow.
There's a system out there there's a whole
new world out there. So not really.
I suppose being keyed into
it's happening in the area.
And i think that's probably a
good thing. So we went ahead and.
The first dance we had actually
the majority of people
that helped us set up the dance were
heterosexual friends who was intriguing
but the dance was a success.
I think we had about one hundred twenty
hundred thirty paying people going in
and then it started from there.
And jesus would have been.
At three
and probably four years ago
now it's a year before.
Years ago. Yeah as a group well
at the time. And see it was.
We use the name of some langauge group
and then it was until about a third
or fourth meeting.
That we decided on a name which
was the tropical fruits. And.
Even for the first i think. Probably.
Seven eight nine meetings we had that
only a handful of us at the meeting.
And the second day and we
put on we had problems.
We actually experience i think
what was a bit of homophobia.
Were told that particular
hole we were using
and a last minute we couldn't use
because the wiring was condemned.
Only a day before the dance was on.
So we had to buy find another ball
quickly which we did quite fortunately.
And then fine.
People just set up to redirect people
to turn a new hole and in spite of all.
That was our second dance we had it
went off really well. Was a great day.
And.
Then i think we had a bit of a lull
in the group at that particular time
and i was signing by then.
That i was doing the gateways
program and then we had this group
and was started putting out a newsletter
as well so doing quite a quite a lot of
different things. And.
Also at that particular time i got
involved a relationship that.
Turned out to be quite present.
I think that was taking more
remote time that it is our go out
and so i tend to let go the group a bit
but unfortunately there were other people
there to take over to get involved
and that's when i think it
really started taking off.
Which i suppose showed me that i
think you can take us things so far
and then you've got to let it go.
And if if it's if it's
meant to happen it will go
and if not it doesn't much work.
So there was well there is virtually
no one at that particular time then
and only for the gateways program
was going and then used to wonder.
As to you know who was if there was anyone
listening to the program because it was
fairly late at night so.
A lot of people deal strict as to listening
to to the program because of the
time slot and then we had problems
that used to be an earlier time slot
that got moved and we
couldn't get it changed back
and we wondered whether part of that might
have been from fear homophobia again.
But apart from that there was there
was no other no network there.
There's an overall net gain a twerk.
Cause i think country network
covers the whole of australia
and i think there were quite
a few people gay people.
Sexual people from this area who
are members of that network.
But apart from that there
was nothing else here.
Then with the group with we had a
magazine which we called through tuesday
and. We may we used to
print that every month.
And then we started linking up with
with other gay groups and other areas
and through the gay media
and the gay press.
We were advertising ourselves
and cause now i think we're
you have a reputation or
that particular think the gay crew the
tropical fruit has a reputation of being the
most. They've all the country network
and.
The dancers who i suppose you get anything
up to three hundred people at a dance
which is quite a lot and. The reputation
for the dancers has seen to be very cool.
Explorer. Just getting back to
the the network around the area.
A lot of things seem to happen at the
same time with doing the radio program
and then the the group in the
newsletter and and the dancers
and there are also got involved
with looking at setting up.
The. A network for people
for hiv positive people.
That there were a group of people
in lismore that were interested
and having meetings and a
particular time to having meetings
that some vincent's hospital. To set up a.
An organ. So i was right. A.
Support group for people who are
hiv positive for our aids people.
And i thought i was
involved with that too.
To a minimal degree mainly because the my
link with the group was a social group
and the radio program.
And what actually happened was
a con was approached in sydney
and they had a person come out to
look at setting up a branch up here
and that's what eventually happens
then we had the aiken branch
and youth our part of the northern
rivers area. The northern district.
Not exactly sean that dates but probably
that would have been a village over
three years ago about three years ago
that. And. With fairly
well established here.
I think they do a lot of
good work around the area
that also there was a
needle exchange program but
that was actually set up by the health
department i think before a con.
And then. I think a kind also
had sort of given a lot.
I helped sort of set up a networking
system as well and i sort of.
Supported by the the tropical
fruits and vice versa.
Even though
that the tropical fruit was actually just
a social group right from the beginning
it was expressed that it should just be
purely for enjoyment and entertainment
and shouldn't be political. In any way.
Though it's always hard to bring colour
ticks into any say they were there was used
to have a we have dance with actually a lot
of the dancers were at repentance creek
all. And then there was
for a little while.
We had no problems with that until they
had a change in the whole committee
and the new committee decided
that then it would have proved
as having dances there but.
That led ended up in a consultation
at one of the meetings. And.
Other on forgotten i'm pretty during
the 13 up of of the gay group
and the social group on the radio program
and the newsletter the magazine.
We also were approached by
and i think it was fred miller at the
time who was one who's involved with the
police gailey a zone group and.
So he came up from sydney and
we had meetings with him
and one of the local pubs in lou's well
and also the local community
police officer and.
Right. Notion it at all.
Anyway we had meetings in.
One of the social venues in lismore and.
Formed also form the police
and gay liaison group for this area.
And also at the time there
were some people who who felt
that we should have some
radical gay group here.
Gay activists and maybe
a branch of act up.
Should be represented here and i
sort of got involved with that also
and so we had to make sure that we that
we didn't involve the social group with
that and there were there was a
time when fred nile came up here
and we we had a bit of a demonstration
at brunswick heads which was televised.
To coincidence.
But what was more interesting was the
reaction from people i walking down the
street people would come up to
me that i never seen before
and i say i saw you on t.v. and I think
they are it's great. I think it's good i.
I like what you're doing. I'm like i
really support you know stuff like that.
So it's very positive stuff
i've got a bit of a blow out.
That that was happening. Right.
Yes there is
and there is so in little more too
apparently other unaware of it until fairly
until after i actually got involved with
was helping set up the gay group the
social gay group that i
discovered there was.
But apart from all that they had
there were little thing with light.
Again i think in some of the local papers
like the northern star in the ekka.
There are articles by people who felt
that you know having radical posters running
around the hills is not a good thing
and that they they found
that they didn't like so.
And of course there's something like
that would happen with you know little
are always be a few of us heard write
articles in reply to that and
explain that you know we're human.
We're people too and you know we
just might turn to be a selves and
that we're not really hurting anyone.
And why should it worry then what we do.
You know.
You know i do have a few like i think them
very any of the president a funny story
about kids.